what up space fam goes in here for enemy
uproar and today we are talking about
the amazing view
definitely one of my favorite characters
in Demon Slayer I said that I'll start
working on this video as soon as we hit
4000 likes on the house strong is in no
escape video and we hit that in less
than a day so here I am right back at it
again with the new how strong is video
we had a bullet on Instagram at enemy
uproar for who the next video would
cover thousands voted and give you ended
up winning over moves on by a pretty
large margin
I guess Q is more popular with fans than
he is with other pillars if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell because if you don't
you won't get notified when future Demon
Slayer videos come out as with the last
two times as soon as the video hits 4000
likes I'll start working on the next one
ASAP and that's with last time I set up
a vote via Instagram stories where you
can help decide whether I cover Mouzon
or rang goku next you can find a link to
our instagram at anime uproar in the
description and in the pin comment below
make sure you're following us there
because i will be doing many more of
these votes in the future let the games
begin if you didn't realize yet there
will be manga spoilers in this video
since i'll be looking at all of the
relevant evidence to help me determine
how strong you is now without further
ado let's jump into it in the beginning
gu is 19 and then 21 after the time-skip
he often wears a serious look on his
face and has trouble communicating with
others nevertheless he's proficient when
it comes to kicking but he makes an
appearance in the very first chapter of
the demon slayer manga he is the OG o p
pillar he tries to save time judo by
killing mezu KO but time zero stops him
at this point he was way more powerful
than 200 oh he's so quick that he steals
vesikko from ton zeros arms in the blink
of an eye before taunted or even
realizes what happened ironically it is
Gil who convinces Tantra to fight him
and Tantra almost lands a surprise
attack on Gil but do you notices in time
and avoids the thrown hatchet demon
azúcar uses this moment to escape his
grasp and moves to protect on zero
although you could easily kill both of
them at this point he lets Natsuko live
because he can see that she's different
from the other demons he does one of
those cool karate chops to the neck and
puts demon as
to sleep like it was nothing he leaves
after telling Tonto to go see the former
water pillar we have to wait until the
demon spider family ark to see one of my
favorite flexes in demon slayer first
queue helps you know ski with the father
spider demon who is arguably the
physically strongest member of the
family his pre transformation skin was
tough but after his transformation
he knows Kay's blades simply break when
he tries to cut him that's how tough
this demon skin is or at least his skin
seemed to be uncuttable until GU shows
up as he knows key points out Hugh is on
a completely different level he cuts
through the demon as if he was tofu aka
effortlessly in contrast to the super
energetic and loud eNOS gay Hugh does
all this quickly and silently never
changing the fixed expression on his
face
then when the almost dead eNOS Kay
starts charging him to a fight he was
quick enough to tie him up with rope and
hang him off a tree branch without eNOS
key even noticing what's happening until
it's all over
all he knows he can do afterwards just
comment how quick you is but even more
than this moment I appreciate the way
Gil deals with lower moon five Louie
episode 19 of the anime where tundra
door unlocks at Dance of the fire god
and let's go unlocked her blood demon
art was arguably one of the best anime
episodes of the year it was extremely
hype after struggling so much both
tundra and net sook will unlock new
powers they use these powers together in
order to make the final attack all the
more powerful then they seemingly
succeed in cutting off through his head
in a glorious moment of cinematic
ecstasy it was a brilliant victory
except it wasn't actually a victory at
all we find out in the next episode that
through he survived by detaching his own
head with his strings way before tangelo
could cut him through he was wrecking
Tonto and that's called the whole time
and even their new strongest tag-team
attack did no damage to Rui Rui truly
seems like an unstoppable beast at this
point
Entergy you as Louie's powerful strings
are closing in to kill taunted o EU
drops in and cuts through them no
problem saving time zero in the process
he tells time zero to leave the rest to
him
Rui launches his most powerful attack to
date and sends it AG you he responds not
by avoiding the attack but by just
standing there
he uses his original breath of water
technique called lull
unravels all of the ruies strings before
they can even reach GU the Rui is
shocked Aggie you somehow stopped his
attack without moving a muscle all the
screaming upgrades and effort possible
couldn't help tangerine does go beat
through E and here's G you making lui
look completely powerless before the Rui
can even launch another attack
EU cuts his head off with the same
unchanged look on his face he looks
bored as he effortlessly defeats this
demon that gave our main characters so
much trouble it goes without saying that
gives blade was too fast for Rui to
detach his own head in time this is
arguably when you strength seems the
most impressive because of the huge gap
between his own power and the power of
Ennis Kate and run as Zuko Android
however as with most o P characters you
can't stay open forever the main
characters have to improve and
increasingly strong enemies have to show
up to keep things interesting so let's
fast forward to time zero and gills
fight with upper moon three Icaza where
the limits of gives powers are tested by
this point Q is amazed at how far time
zero has come even at the beginning of
the battle gear mentions a touch of
those power matches that of a pillar
both grow during the battle I cuz
there's someone so strong any man just
to overwhelm Gil despite the fact that
no one's done that in a long while this
life-and-death struggle increases new
skills and causes his demon sir mark to
manifest EU is impressive and for a good
while EU is able to match a cos øz blows
however goo eventually realizes that as
slices are too shallow and then akasa
punches his sword and breaks it
our Castle does complement you on how
long he lasted but even with the demon
mark
he was just no match for Icaza even law
can't absorb aqus attacks EU must be
saved by tangelo who now has access to
the see-through world and has awakened
the new and extremely opie non self
state as akiza mentions tangelo has
reached the supreme state that he always
wanted to reach tonzura uses the state
to cut off Acosta's head before he can
respond however alcazar caches has said
and tries to put it back
EU throws his broken sword at the head
and it falls to the ground
however akiza starts fighting with no
head tangelo who's reached his limit
faints and he was ready to defend him
with his life after the amount of damage
Q's taken
it's extremely impressive they can still
stand and try to fight even though he's
obviously outmatched
luckily Icaza regains his memories and
decides to self-destruct and stop or
generating even though he reached a
stage where he could have grown his
whole head back like mousse on a Kasai
uses the annihilation technique he used
against him Goku on himself rather than
on Tangier oh and you this technique was
called destructive death annihilation
type and it mortally wounded and Goku
although he didn't immediately die from
it
so that is what we've seen from goo so
far with the manifestation of the mark
he's stronger than he's ever been before
finally against Icaza he's been pushed
beyond his limits in a way he hasn't
been pushed up to now however despite
the fact that he's stronger than ever
he doesn't seem as opie as he used to in
this battle Dungeness seem to have
surpassed him in power if not in
endurance after all while GU could
barely scratch off as his neck Thanh
Judah was quick and strong enough to cut
off his head he even warned de caza and
aquas ah still couldn't stop him we
can't just explain tons of a successful
attack by saying that akiza couldn't
sense him because Icaza was looking at
him he saw him coming and he still
couldn't do anything to stop the attack
it is worth mentioning though that
tundra fainted while GU was still
standing at fighting but when he was
fighting he wasn't nearly as strong as
tundra was and has non-self state in
terms of strength we know that yi was
strong but for the purposes of this
video we need to try to clarify how
strong he is exactly for the time being
it seems clear that he was not on our
castles level or even on tangelos level
right now it's no small accomplishment
that he was able to last as long as he
did against akiza but the fact is that
he was fighting a losing battle even
though he could occasionally rely on
Tundra dose health and aqus didn't even
use his annihilation technique that he
used to give it and Goku a mortal wound
I would for the time being though put
him above Sonny 20 no escape although
Sonny to beat an upper moon by himself
Kai gaku was the weakest upper Moon and
on top of that he was not used to his
powers in contrast akiza was an
extremely strong opponent and one can
even argue that he would have become
stronger than upper moon to DOMA if he
let his head grow back
q wasn't as powerful as our Casa but I
think he fared better than sunny - or
eNOS gay would have at this point even
with ton judo we should keep in mind
that although his power temporarily
spiked in his new state he couldn't
maintain that state for long
well GU fought an impressively long time
without reaching his body's limit and
passing out and that is how strong you
is currently he is a strong pillar but
he's no longer the opie figure he used
to be it's hard if not impossible to
keep up with protagonist powers after
all I'll talk more about how I think
cannon Goku would fare against ki when I
eventually make that how strong is an
Goku video however if you did enjoy this
one make sure to smash that like button
to let me know
remember if we hit 4,000 likes I'll
guess around the next one ASAP remember
to vote for either Ren Goku or moves on
on Instagram at Anime uproar if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell because you won't
get notified when the new video drops if
you don't a big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one impossible I
especially want to thank our pro here to
your patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing about a fan Jason Wilson King's
eldest angel Cruz Steelers poet Pablo
atropos rate $30 beat Akagi and anatoly
Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel and Matteo and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans Stephen and Radha
al-hola Gotham Matty Mac 239 makoto-kun
and you boys set if you enjoy our work
you can support forward by going over to
patreon.com/scishow a uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll gain name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patient only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]